are you all right I'm all right but
you've nearly frightened the life out of
him hmm this bag we're hunting see it's
what's done just because it's what's
done doesn't mean it's what should be
done you're right I hope to see you
again miss ragged servant girl is what
you are and that is what you will always
be that wonderful girl I can't stop
thinking about it you will be king soon
her prince is not free to follow his
heart you must marry for the good of the
kingdom what have you been doing
dreaming let's hope oh then wake up no
one in the kingdom will outshine my
daughter
it's you could just say
remember but the pastor could be right
the spell will be broken for and all the
water turn toward a hospital are you
looking for this must be quite a story
to go with it keep that girl out of
sight and you and your daughters will
get whatever you desire someone like
that doesn't just vanish I have to see
her again
I will protect the prince from you
no matter what becomes of me